right these are both airpods Pro but  these are the new airpods Pro you can  kind of tell by the updated case I think  one of the coolest things about this new  case though is that it works with  wireless chargers and the magsafe puck  this is what the old one looks like on a  magsafe puck doesn't really stay in  place you can line it up eventually but  if you just bump it it might not charge  case  makes a little chime and it it's rock  solid it actually lines itself up and  that's because bring in the magnet paper  there's a new array of magnets on the  back of the case here to help it line up  which is super sick this is the old one  you can see the headphones have little  magnets in them but that's that's not  the array that's what's sticking to the  magsafe  very cool